Victor wiim minyama ton of hype around
him how would you say as a peer you're
most excited for him to continue to grow
his game and what's it like sharing the
floor with him he's going to be a beast
in this league as long as he can play
his presence on the floor alone is
impactful and just on defense offense he
can do pretty much everything and it's
everything that everybody's been saying
about him and you can tell he's humble
he competes he wants to work hard so he
has all the intangibles to be the best
player ever the accolades and team
accolades as his career goes on is
what's going to determine that so you
definitely has the
[Music]
tools